[Music]
so
okay
[Music]
if you've been tempted to resign your
job because of the great resignation
then this one's for you hello everybody
my name is mayuko and welcome back to my
channel where i talk about tech career
and life stuff so it's hard to read the
news these days without coming across
the whole great resignation
millions of americans are resigning
their jobs right now for probably a lot
of different reasons i think it's maybe
because kovit has forced us to kind of
slow down and reevaluate what we really
want in life and now that vaccines are
out and stuff and things are starting to
look a little brighter we're all taking
steps to live the life that we all want
and you know what i think that's fine if
that's like your motivation to like
resign your job honestly i'm not here to
talk about that today like why you
should or shouldn't leave your job
because that is such an individual
journey case-by-case situation like just
so many factors that you're the only
person who can make that decision but
what i did want to talk about
it's just like
how do you actually do it you know as a
friend for me to you maybe we're new
friends hello nice to meet you like how
do you do it responsibly what are the
things that you think about just like
i'm just here to give y'all
some advice i suppose if you want it if
you wanted to talk to somebody about
this whole great resignation thing
granted this is
very one way but
i've thought a lot about how like i go
about resigning jobs and so yeah just
wanted to have a little comfy cozy tea
time where we talk about that today by
the way thank you to brilliant for
sponsoring today's video if you'd like
to learn more about brilliant that you
can check the link in description box
down below or stick around to the end of
the video so a lot of my friends
colleagues and stuff they're all
switching jobs they're all quitting jobs
they're all doing all of this i've quit
a couple of jobs now and i've feel like
i have this formula for how i think
about quitting jobs and one of the
things that i'm thinking about to make
sure that i can quit them responsibly
because as a very risk-averse
woman who needs to
fend for herself in this day and age in
america
whatever else that all comes with
i always leave jobs responsibly the
unfortunate thing about america ish
i don't know if it's unfortunate but it
just is the way that it is is that you
can't like just leave your job and
everything else stays in place
unfortunately there's a lot of things
tied up in employment in america of
course the salary and your livelihood is
one part but also things like health
insurance and your financial investments
and stuff like that can also be tied up
in your whole employment and so i think
it's important you know that if you're
thinking or you've decided to leave to
like do it responsibly i suppose by the
way i don't know if any and all this
advice is gonna apply to you per se but
me coming from a tech background asian
american background background in which
i don't like burning bridges or getting
rid of opportunities that i don't need
to get rid of this is these are just all
my thoughts so just keep that in mind
these are very subjective my two cents
so if you're thinking about quitting i
think my question would be like what
what are you gonna do after you quit
like what what's your plan if you have
one you know and i think that really
depends on your comfort level and your
risk tolerance because
you know if you're pretty risk-averse
you're probably gonna have or want to
have a job lined up after you quit your
current one or if you're pretty okay
with risk then you might be like i don't
know i'm just gonna see where the wind
takes me and see what happens
if you're gonna get another job then you
know best about that you are going to
know what you have to do in order to get
that job it probably looks similar to
how you got your current job you're
going to know better about what roles
are out there and how to interview in
the timeline of interviews so i'm going
to leave you with that because you know
how to do this so you know if you're
chilling like maybe you need to find
time to like rediscover yourself or you
just gotta
recover from some burnout or whatever
that might be you just like need a break
that's that's cool but for me when i'm
like just trying to chill i always need
some sort of backup plan
because
like the world will keep on moving
without you even if you're chilling a
lot of people talk about having like
three months of like living expenses as
a rule of thumb to have in your savings
account um for this kind of chillin
period or even really just as like a
good backup you know because you know i
like i always think of like what's the
worst that could happen like what is
what if i don't feel like going back to
work in three months
or i do feel like going back to work in
three months will i reasonably be able
to find a job so another part of the
calculation for this whole like just
chilling scenario is
like thinking about how reasonably you
could get a job again if you really
needed to in a pinch
because you know what you can't control
what happens in life
and in the world and to you like
so many different things can happen and
sometimes
in that period you're gonna need a job
whether it be for income or for health
insurance or for stability or whatever
i think it's just an important thing to
factor in even if you really don't want
to think about work right now um at the
end of the day we gotta support
ourselves and we have to do what we have
to do in order to survive and thrive so
yeah make sure you leave enough money in
your savings um whenever i left a job
and i was just chilling i made a
spreadsheet you can see it here of all
of my expenses of like what do i need to
do to do life
and just be really realistic about that
and then figure out okay how long do i
want to be chilling
multiply those months times the expenses
and i have how much i should have in my
savings or at least how much i should
have before i
reasonably run out of some sort of
expendable money that i don't mind
spending so yes you know expenses is a
big thing to think about when you're
leaving your job and i know you've
probably thought about this like that's
probably one of the
things that like stuff ain't free
rent isn't free food isn't free so i'm
sure you've thought about it but you
know just in case you have it she wanted
to let you know because
uh it's one thing that really helps you
to be realistic about this whole
quitting thing
and also if you're the type that you're
just like a free spirit and you're fine
with like leaving your job and you
haven't done the math that's fine too
but just so long as you're also willing
to like deal with it like as long as you
take responsibility for your choices
honestly that's fine and also at the end
of the day like your life is yours it's
not mine so like i'm not trying to
dictate
what you should or shouldn't do
it's just if i were to do it this is how
i would think about it all right so the
next thing
healthcare healthcare is heavily tied to
your employment in the united states
and chances are if you're full-time
employed you also got your healthcare
from your employer unless you have a
partner or you're a dependent or
something like that this always depends
on your policy obviously and your
provider and stuff like that but if you
have health care through your employer
it's gonna disappear at some point so a
lot of the times it'll be until the end
of the calendar month that you quit
sometimes to the end of the year i don't
think that's actually super common um i
know for my vision and dental i think
insurance it usually goes until the end
of the calendar year for for like health
medical bills and stuff like that it's
usually to the end of the month so for
health healthcare disappears then how
are you going to get healthcare because
it's important to be insured in case
something happens the u.s department of
labor provides something called cobra
which stands for consolidated omnibus
budget reconciliation act it basically
allows you to continue your health
insurance your current policy your
current provider after you finish or you
quit or you leave a job or something
like that but you have to pay
the insurance out of pocket and
oftentimes it's really really expensive
i think for mine when i left patreon
cobra was like 600 a month or something
like that
and you know that's expensive when
you're not making any income uh at least
it was for me at the time so if you're
someone who has a lot of medical bills
or you suffer ski certain medical bills
or operations or things that need to
come up for me i always take care of my
eyes and so i always think about like
all right well gotta get my annual
checkup on my eyes because they're
really bad and i also gotta get my
contacts and stuff like that i will kind
of plan my leave
around that basically and there's also
other benefits right like not just
health care but also like maybe you get
a gym stipend or you get like commuter
benefits or you get education
stipend or something like that those all
disappear when you leave and so just
make sure you're like taking care of
that
and you're like
good and letting things go or you have
an option to continue them it could also
include things like stock options which
you should definitely check when's the
last day you can buy your options or buy
your stocks or whatever because that can
you know make a difference in your
financial future too i think the last
thing that like i always
really take care of in doing like
whenever i leave a job is to really take
care of my relationships like i don't
want to burn bridges if i don't have to
i guess
because you just never know what's gonna
happen in life you know like you might
do a career switch or you might take a
career fall or you might end up working
with one person you had one interaction
with once
and so your first impression on that
person really matters like so many
different things can happen in life
that i always think about like how can i
leave the most doors open for myself
without
compromise
and also without hurting my chances of
anything per se and so realistically to
me that means when i'm leaving a job i
keep really warm positive relationships
with the people at the company that i'm
leaving so even if like the company that
i'm leaving i'm like not happy with it
it's
usually like not the case that it's the
people that i worked with that i'm
unhappy about per se like directly and
so
my managers and stuff like that i i've
had a really warm relationship with them
my co-workers and stuff too because
here's the thing like if you work in any
industry it tends to be that the
industry is pretty small
and so i feel like reputation is also
kind of important not for like vanity
things but it's just for like future
opportunities how people perceive you is
also going to
result in real life opportunities and
benefits and stuff like that and so
i mean really all it comes down to is
just being nice and respectful and
communicative also because you might
need to go back to that job one day like
you just never know like there's such
thing as like a boomerang job where you
start at a company and then you leave
that company but then you end up
boomeranging back
so if you ever really need that job back
or you really want that job back after
some distance even if you know you're
not gonna go back it's always just good
to keep your options open
and you know the whole thing about like
leaving jobs is like it's a privileged
position to be in you either don't need
a job because you can afford not to have
a job or
you have a lot of different options for
jobs which is also a privileged position
so i think it's important to honor that
that you have and accept that you have
the privilege um and then sometimes just
take that opportunity if you if you want
to and need it and because you can don't
do it just because everyone else is
doing it you know like
that it's it's like you just you have to
make decisions for your own self and
what's best for you because you're the
only person who knows what's best for
you and you have to advocate for
yourself
um i think with the internet and with
information and stuff like that we all
are learning and really
truly learning how different we are from
one another
and how the human experience cannot be
summed into one sentence one paragraph
one book or really anything at all
because we're all just so different from
each other and when we all really
actually don't know each other that well
the only person we can guarantee that we
know well
is ourselves
so
as much as i know it's like
very
easy to go with the crowd and do what
you feel like you want to do because
everyone else is doing it
do it because you want to do it you know
like do it because it's right for you
and your journey and your future
i think that's what like
leaving your job responsibly means
and
you know it's a hard decision to make
i'm not gonna lie about that every one
of my jobs that i left it was very
difficult and i cried a lot
about them either because it was hard or
because i was sad or because i was
frustrated or whatever so yeah you know
just leaving a job is a very personal
decision and i respect whatever you do
at the end of the day and you also will
never quite know if this decision was
the right one so you gotta just trust
your gut trust your instincts really
listen to what you want and then maybe
down the road you'll figure out
how this decision affected others but
you know it'll be okay you'll get there
like every it'll all be fine just do it
responsibly and
do what's right for you so
if you're thinking of leaving your job
and you're either thinking of learning
some new skills or maybe taking the time
to learn something new while you're away
from your job then definitely check out
brilliant brilliant is a problem-solving
based website and app with a hands-on
approach with over 60 interactive
courses in math science and computer
science all of brilliant courses are
really interactive because they really
believe in learning by doing instead of
just watching lectures or something so
they have some really great courses on
computer science for example if you've
always been thinking about learning how
to code like python for instance is a
really popular first programming
language to learn and so they've got a
course on that too of course there's no
tests or grades for any of these and you
can take these courses at your own pace
if you'd like to join me in a community
of 8 million learners and educators
today click the link in the description
box down below or visit brilliant.org
hellomyuco thanks everybody so much for
watching today's video and i'll see you
next time bye
you